a tres días de las elecciones generales
en bolivia la incertidumbre se extiende
entre los ciudadanos las amenazas de
sectores afines al movimiento al
socialismo más de orquestar un estallido
social si hay irregularidades en los
comicios sumado a la confusión difundida
en redes sociales llevó a los ciudadanos
a sacar el pasaporte para poder dejar el
país si es el caso y aglomerarse para
abastecerse de lo básico sin importar la
pandemia ayer tuve que hacer una larga
fila para llenar el caso el combustible
para mi movilidad nos ha estado casi
toda la ciudad los mercados están
abarrotados
no es normal la gente anda con miedo
anda con pavor hay mucho malentendido
creo que piensan que después de las
elecciones va a haber otro conflicto
aquí y pues la abastecen de gasolina
incluso ahí están hablando de que el
precio del huevo va a subir pero él como
19 no es el único obstáculo presenta en
estos comicios es el proceso electoral
más complejo de la historia democrática
de bolivia lo era incluso antes de la
llegada de la pandemia al país porque
tenía este proceso electoral un punto de
partida complejo difícil que fue la
anulación de la elección de 2019 las
graves denuncias de fraude electoral
hicieron imposible darle la victoria al
entonces presidente evo morales que
terminó renunciando al cargo y
abandonando el país
desde entonces bolivia arrastra una
crisis política y social que dejó 37
muertos y más de 800 heridos en las
protestas que le siguieron a las
fallidas elecciones y aunque ahora la
disputa de electorales entre el
exministro de economía luis arce cercano
a evo el ex presidente carlos mesa y el
candidato conservador luis fernando
camacho la paranoia y la división
continúan ganando terreno en medio de
las grietas que se abrieron el año
pasado